on sait que l'esma la saison des courses
reprend ce week-end de pâques les
meilleurs régionaux disputait le grand
prix de valentin une course de 130 km
remporté par l'amicale cycliste
bisontine et son coureur gwenaël rouzet
la mb s'offre même un doublé sur le
podium
déception en revanche pour les erbatons
une course que nous raconte élisabeth
braconniers et jean-marie pas vrai entre
les jaune et bleu de la mcb et les
oranges des tubes on attendait un duel
sans merci
autant dire que le contrat a été rempli
côté bisontin 15 coureurs au départ côté
erbatons deux fois moins mais avec un
favori
thibaut pinot vainqueur de la première
manche de ce challenge régional gros
effectif assez conséquent
on va se battre comme on peut tu verras
parcours ouais c'est un parcours assez
usant sur la fin la cub on bosse donc je
pensais sur la fin car son départ lancés
de miserey-salines puis cap sur
pouilley-les-vignes show scène hemani et
auxon dessous et sa fameuse bosse à
parcours immeuble de 24 kilomètres à
effectuer cinq fois très vite une
dizaine d'hommes se détachent parmi eux
dix beaux pineau et cinq coéquipiers du
cc etupes mais à auxon le peloton var
paul est un classique et un scénario qui
se renouvellera à cinq reprises dans le
quatrième tour c'est encore le sait ses
tubes qui prend l'initiative thomas
bouteille s'échappe avec le mulhousien
steinberger mais là encore les deux
hommes seront repris par le peloton au
final l'arrivée se joue au sprint et
c'est un outsider qui l'emportent le
bisontin gwenaël rouzet était très
nerveux
donc ça râlait rouler roulent énormément
bon on a regroupé tous deux de 25 ans
sont au pied de la bosse j'arrive à
sortir de l'ombre
là j'avais fait de l'an passé n'a
pourtant gagné sur lucerne thurgovie les
gens mais tu es un petit pot limit sur
la fin c'était un rythme un peu élevé
pour moi est bon ben je connaissais bien
arriver nous j'ai fait tout mon courage
vraiment et pas très content 6e place
incroyable pour un invité d'honneur dont
les titres de gloire se joue sur deux
roues et sur le bitume mais avec un
moteur
le quadruple champion du monde
d'endurance moto a tenu la dragée haute
à près de 80 coureurs grande classe
[Musique]